Michele
decided fans now I know that this here is
your first gold film that what
was your experience
well let's say it was a
unique experience because I discovered
Federico's personality and being
a man of cinema for many years I think I am
having discovered through this
experience a great talent
this is already a very very
important thing for me n sync film in
defense what you liked a lot
more working with federico his
immediate idea of what is an actio
of a horror film c  'is
the execution of an idea that is instantaneous
and instant he is not very much
thought I do not know how to say he is like
a painter who makes the canvas at the moment this is
so and this is a very rare
dangerous thing special person like a hole
in the four by shaun white noise and qui
listing che il follo steve eastin is
like a pretending know when he start page
speed torino i doesn't exist hingis
things and he doesn't media tweed
housing in su ma tubo da follow any kind
of  between  ditional way